so then we moved on and once we've done
that and then we kind of came back to
the syllabus and we blitz through it and
one of the things was trigonometry and
we did just some basic trick and then I
said right I want you to measure the
height of that tree at the front and so
they estimated it they went around the
school asking people what they thought
it was and then they had to come up with
how to actually measure it and I didn't
give him anything I just literally said
measure it um and they failed you know
that it was an scaffolded it was a good
group task because they had to kind of
use ingenuity and creativity it's
actually quite different from doing a
question in the book I didn't realize
how difficult it was to actually measure
a tree because just finding the angle
without giving been given an inkling no
meter or a sextant or ending and it's
quite tricky and so they just grabbed my
protractor board protractor and they
went to the dt workshop and got a piece
of tubing which they thought was quite a
good way of doing it and then they
measured different distances away from
the tree and they've got a variety of
measurements then they did the
trigonometry and and then they average
their results it turns out that the tree
was actually 50 meters and known for
looks that high so that was quite an
interesting for them and there was no
spoon feeding it involved a lot of group
work and a lot of peer teaching and
learning which I thought was pretty cool
and then we published an article in the
school newsletter about it so again gave
him a sense of self-esteem it was
something no one else had done and they
got to go outside and walk around a bit
so another example here's another
example of the same class what we did
and they were going on an outbound camp
at the end of the year and so I thought
it was an ideal opportunity to get them
to do some construction and also learn
about the Southern Cross and navigation
so those of you who don't know the way
to find South you basically draw a line
through the long diagonal of the
Southern Cross and you find the pointers
stars and you draw a perpendicular
bisector through the point of stars and
where those two lines meet you drop a
purpose
drop a perpendicular to the horizontal
and i created this in geogebra and i had
a solution sheep and i did three
different versions and then basically
that Seth and they got to actually
practice their construction it gave them
a really and a good incentive to be as
accurate as possible because I held it
up to the life and if they were bang on
and again worked in some kind of doggy
stem for some reward which was worth
something um and yeah I'll talk a little
bit more about rewards at the end of
this talk because that's something I'm
very passionate about school school-wide
rewards for effort which actually worked
just as well as cash in chocolates so um
this is for no particular reason I just
think it's pretty those of you haven't
seen it and I'll play it to you it shows
how infuriating teaching can be from
YouTube so here's your first lieutenant
injections um what or take away why
won't we
shakily what six take away one no you
take away so you take away one out of
six how much is mine is one I don't know
one two three four five six six nine six
one two three six one two three four
five six seven eight oh one more you add
one more evil one 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 10 9 8
when you take away one N equals 0
do you get it now this one just isn't
that your worst night I think that's
brilliant as nice that it uses kids
voices as well and there's a whole
series of those and but you know we do
need infinite patience to be teachers
and and you have to go through concept
again and again again again
reinforcements I mean that's how
learning takes place you hear teachers
in the in the common room sort of saying
I told them three times and they still
don't get it well tell on the fourth
time or a fifth time I mean obviously if
i were to teach you guys how to say the
numbers in time from one to 10 notes on
Sam see ha hop jet bad County okay can
you remember that you know yeah sure I
do again do you think you'll remember it
then how many times will I have to do
well clearly quite a few because it's a
new concept so don't be afraid don't
think you're a bad teacher because they
don't get it because it just means they
need reinforcements um I kind of liken
am I Tomac kids this I sort of start
usually in a new topic and I just teach
the whole topic in my lesson big
holistic you know no pens just like it's
have an exploration of the topic and
then the next lesson I start from the
beginning or maybe I start somewhere
else and I'm constantly doing this it's
almost like sort of polishing a table
I'm coming back and going forward coming
back pairing food so I'm going beyond
what we need to do and I'm coming back
and revisiting concepts and I tell them
that so that they understand my crazy
methods and that they're not worried
about it and they will come back to it
anyway and here's my mother oh sorry was
in there and colleague of mine said
bottom set I I don't like the word
bottom set but you understand what i
mean and unconfident mobility order year
seven person trying to introduce algebra
and you know that's a pretty difficult
concept and so I thought of an idea
I haven't actually tried this but he
said it worked really well which was
using these kind of unit blocks and he
just kind of chucked a whole load
together and gave each of them some kind
of shape thing solid made with these
things and he asked them to basically
say how many yellow blocks there were
how many green blocks how many blue box
blocks and so on and to represent that
in some way so you know started writing
down so many green so many blue and some
of them you know immediately started
writing their 3g 5b seven why and so on
and and then basically he you know he
found instinctively they were taking the
solid apart I said can I take it apart
and do what you like so they're taking
it apart and sticking back together with
all the yellows together all the greens
together too and how great is that
because it's something actually they can
touch and feel and then representing it
as letters instead of like writing out
green and yellow and was actually a
relief to them you know they didn't have
to do all that writing so that was a
great way of symbolic representation of
algebra and it's all about building
confidence in year 7 and 8 particularly
in those sets I have a very strong
belief that we shouldn't be assessing
and testing kids in year 7 and 8 to be
getting anything less than sixty percent
I mean if it's up to me i given fifty
percent for adding the name correctly I
think that we need to give them some
very very basic questions as being the
at least half the exam so that they have
a chance to actually show that they know
something and they don't get smashed
with their confidence because once you
put that light out it's very very hard
to get it started again so you're 78 i
believe is all about nurture um so
here's a lightening up trigonometry bit
get it okay and so I've just been
teaching some trigonometry to your 11
again and and I'll show you some of the
things I've sort of put into just try
and live in an up a bit and make it more
of a real topic this is the most
wonderful applet and and there are
others like it I actually use I use this
with the extension to mechanics and but
how good is this it just shows you the
link oh why is that not work sorry
no okay this is one of these the
problems with having the extended screen
I can see something nice here you can
let's try this
ok now I can see that
there we go so this shows the link
between circular motion simple harmonic
motion and and sinusoid and it also
shows you that basically simple harmonic
motion can be represented by any
sinusoid by a cost sine and cosine or
sine function and she's pretty nice
isn't it shows how trigonometry are
beyond 90 degrees can be found in all
aspects of of nature